You've all heard the story
about girls' education.
It goes like this:
To end poverty, educate a girl.
To tackle climate change, educate a girl.
To solve the health crisis,
educate a girl.
It seems like girls' education
is the closest thing we have
to an actual silver bullet.
There's just one problem.
When you send a girl to school
without radically reshaping
the support structures around her,
you're just putting a diploma in her hand.
If she gets that far.
And slotting her right back
into a world of poverty and inequality.
What's more,
as one of the few survivors
of a system stacked against her,
she'll feel isolated and overwhelmed
by all of the expectations
of how her education
will somehow change everything.
I remember primary school in Zimbabwe
where a teacher would tell
his top pupil to hide in a toilet
whenever the inspectors came
because they would send her home
for not paying her levies.
Her experience of isolation,
crouching barefoot in a torn dress
over a pit in a concrete cubicle
only intensified when she received
a scholarship to secondary school.
One of the few to get this chance,
she was wracked by guilt.
Her own mom had sold
two buckets of maize
to buy her a blanket
and a toothbrush for boarding school.
That meant her family would give up
many meals to see her through.
How was she ever
going to repay this investment?
This girl often thought of dropping out.
Imagine suffering survivor's guilt
just for being in school.
Imagine feeling the pressure,
not just to address
your own family poverty,
but to be the solution
to the world's problems.
To change her trajectory and reap
the benefits of girls' education,
we have to lift the burden
placed on the shoulders
of each single girl,
the pressure to beat the odds on her own
and to suddenly make
the world a better place
for everyone when they do.
I'm excited to tell you
there is a growing sisterhood
of educated young women in Africa
who are doing just that.
Thank you.
(Applause)
They know firsthand the complex web
of barriers to girls' education
that extends well beyond the school gates.
They have felt the effects
of poverty and hunger,
child marriage and teen pregnancy.
And now they are ensuring that vulnerable
girls have a sister to lean on
in the classroom
and throughout their lives.
Part of the Campaign for Female
Education, CAMFED,
these women spearhead a model
that helps girls thrive in school
and equip them with the skills
and support network
they need to succeed.
Armed with agency and confidence,
girls change the trajectory
of their own lives
and together tackle
the structural inequality
that holds women back.
We provide girls with financial
and material support
for school basics like decent clothes,
notebooks and menstrual products
in a context where one month's supply
can cost as much as 20 meals.
We built and nurture
a social support network around girls,
community committees
that safeguard children,
parents who cook school meals
and build safe toilets,
chiefs who tackle child marriage
and lift women's voices up.
Crucially, the graduates
who join our sisterhood
return to the classroom to accompany girls
on the journey through school
to independence.
We've done this for decades
and know how successful it is.
These sisters are leaders
who lift each other up
and ensure that no girl
has to carry the weight of poverty
and expectations on her own.
When you have a job interview,
a sister will lend you a dress.
When you apply for university,
a sister will talk you through the jargon.
You know, when you move
to a different district,
a sister will introduce you
to her networks.
And when you face challenges
in your business,
a sister will loan you money
and ask that you pay it
forward to another.
When you have a sick family member,
a sister will show up in the hospital.
In some cases,
we have so many sisters show up,
they have to be turned away.
(Laughter)
Finishing school is just the start
of a challenging journey for a rural girl.
It's the success of women
who have gone before her,
who succeeded before her,
that show her what's possible.
And as more girls graduate,
that journey becomes easier.
This is not just about a tool
to solve the world's hardest problems.
It's a story about communities
joining forces in a model
that sees girls' education as the route
to agency and leadership.
And the benefits are clear to see.
Our CAMFED association is now
more than a quarter of a million
young women strong.
(Applause)
And more than 56,000 members hold local,
national and international
leadership positions.
But the most important thing
about this sisterhood
is our multiplier effect.
The average member financially supports
the education of at least
three more girls.
And as the sisterhood flywheel
spins faster and faster,
young women sit at decision-making tables,
change gender norms
and ensure millions more girls benefit.
I know the impact this will have
on vulnerable girls
because I was one of them.
Remember that girl
hiding from the inspectors
and worrying how to pay back
her mom's sacrifice?
That was me.
I was one of the first girls
supported by CAMFED in Zimbabwe.
And today,
I'm the CEO of the very organization
that sent me to school.
(Cheers and applause)
And what keeps me sane and energized
during the toughest of times
is the sisterhood I co-founded,
which sits at the heart of our programs.
It’s a safe space
where you can show up as you are
and leave better than when you came.
The kind of space
all of us need to thrive.
So believe me when I tell you,
girls' education is the silver bullet.
But only, only, if you do it right.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)